[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue sur tv 78
pour un nouveau numéro du 7 8 sociétés
votre rendez vous hebdomadaire où on
discute des sujets qui font l'actualité
15 5 milliards d'euros supplémentaires
pour financer les aides d'urgence mises
en place dès mars 2020 mais aussi la fin
du quoi qu'il en coûte ce sont deux des
principales annonces faites par bruno le
maire ministre de l'économie des
finances et de la relance alors à
l'heure où l'activité reprend peu à peu
en france quelles sont les aides pour
lutter contre les défaillances
d'entreprises et on en parle avec nos
invités marie le bec bonsoir bonsoir
vous êtes député la république en marge
de la 4ème circonscription des yvelines
et vous êtes membre de la commission des
finances et xavier aubry bonsoir bonsoir
vous êtes président du tribunal de
commerce de versailles
marie le bec justement l'activité a
repris le 19 mai dernier avec la ford du
troisième confinement il était temps de
mettre fin aux quoi qu'il en coûte
bien je crois que dans le discours que
nous avons engagé vis-à-vis des
entreprises c'était à la fois de dire
tant que cette crise perdurera l'état
répondra présent et vous accompagnera
dans la mesure du possible pour
justement éviter les défaillances
d'entreprises éviter les pertes
d'emplois et ça je crois que c'était
absolument fondamental dans le cadre de
la 2 delà du maintien de l'activité
économique mais en même temps nous avons
toujours eu un discours très clair et
c'est que son discours qui est demandé
par les entreprises
c'est d'accepter le fait que à un moment
donné dans un format consentement mutuel
les entreprises avec les entreprises
l'état se désengagera de ces dispositifs
d'accompagnement à des engagements qui
sera très progressif puisqu'il prendra
en compte les évolutions du secteur
alors les aides ne vont pas s'arrêter
tout de suite malgré tout bruno le maire
a annoncé 15 5 milliards d'euros
supplémentaires
oui tout à fait puisque dans on passe
une nouvelle doctrine du quoi qu'il en
coûte
une nouvelle étape finalement et c'est
plutôt quoi qu'il arrive et avec cette
idée de dire il ya des secteurs qui vont
toujours connaître un certain nombre de
difficultés dans le cadre de leur
reprise et il faut pouvoir les
accompagner
on sait qu'il ya des secteurs qui ont
été fermés pendant longtemps comme les
restaurants comme les hôtels qu'ils
peuvent rencontrer un certain nombre de
difficultés pour pouvoir les accompagner
progressivement et on sait qu'on a aussi
certains secteurs comme la souris rats
et authentique quatrième automobiles qui
ont connu des difficultés structurelles
très importante et compteront continuer
à accompagner doux c'est cet argent
supplémentaire qui est engagée c'est
vraiment pour avoir une réponse qui est
plus souple et sur les entreprises
on estime que très grande difficulté et
qui m'ont encore besoin d'accompagnement
de l'état et xavier aubry depuis mars
2020 de nombreux secteurs ont pu
bénéficier de nombreuses de nombreuses
aides pg les prêts garantis par l'état
le fonds de soutien à l'activité
partielle
malgré tout est ce qu'au tribunal de
verre de commerce de versailles on voit
un pic de fermetures de sociétés ou en
fait est-ce que c'est trop tôt pour
estimer les conséquences de la crise
sanitaire
alors j'ai peut-être étonné beaucoup de
nos téléspectateurs
parce que en fait l'année 2020 en termes
de difficultés d'entreprises et plus
particulièrement d'entreprises qui sont
venus ce qu'on appelle en procédure
collective c'est de la soie pour un
redressement judiciaire soit
malheureusement directement pour une
liquidation judiciaire
et bien ce nombre en 2020 par rapport à
2019 a baissé de 40% dont j'y vois là un
effort tout à fait considérables liées
aux aides de l'état pour que
effectivement un grand nombre
d'entreprises finalement n'est pas
recours à ses procédures pour faire face
à leurs difficultés
donc c'est un point très positif disons
le et chaque semestre depuis l'année
dernière nous nous disons au tribunal eh
bien on va voir absolument une montée en
nombre deux ouvertures de procédures
collectives ses nus manga
même en ce moment ce n'est pas le cas
donc nous constatons effectivement une
diminution très sensible alors est ce
que c'est le calme avant la tempête ça
c'est toute la question
ce que je voulais dire aussi c'est que
la situation des yvelines n'est pas
particulière de ce point de vue là tous
les tribunaux de commerce nous et en
nous échangerons avec nos collègues
connaissent même situation
donc c'est plutôt positif et il semble
que au fur et à mesure que effectivement
on va sortir du coin lui en coûte le
débranchement des perfusions comme nous
disons un petit peu simplement va se
faire lentement et dans ces conditions
on peut peut-être pensé qu' il n'y aura
pas une avalanche d'ouverture de
procédures collectives donc de
disparition de l'entreprise et par
conséquent également de restructuration
ou diminution de l'emploi dans le
département
et ça c'est la bonne nouvelle qui au
final est bien aussi des muses
immatriculations il y en a qui se
lancent la crise n'a pas fait peur
absolument et encore une fois en 2020 on
a eu un rebond du nombre d'ouvertures de
société alors disons surtout c'est que
ce sont des auto entrepreneurs ou ce
sont des entreprises individuelles qui
se sont créés mais c'est bon signe c'est
à dire d'un côté effectivement on a des
craintes de par disparaître les
entreprises en raison de leurs
difficultés
mais d'un autre côté on constate une
très grande dynamique pour voir se créer
des entreprises
il faut simplement s'assurer que ce sont
des entreprises qui resteront viable
prendra un certain nombre d'années parce
que il est un fait possible que beaucoup
d'entreprises nes mais aussi meurt
rapidement dans les deux premières
années généralement de leur création
parce que et ça c'est le grand problème
des entreprises françaises n ont pas
assez de fonds propres c'est à dire de
capitaux ont été mis dans l'entreprise
pour son démarrage est ce que m'avait le
bec on peut dire aussi que les
entreprises sont rentrés dans une
certaine résilience
oui je crois effectivement que les
chiffres
donner un cadeau et le président du
tribunal de commerce sont assez
significatifs on voit bien qu'il ya
beaucoup moins de défaillances
d'entreprises et c'est notamment à cause
des aides d'état mais aussi parce que je
pense qu'on a su donner des éléments de
confiance et de prévisibilité qui ont
fait que finalement les entreprises ont
su trouver les ressources internes
nécessaires pour pour s'adapter
ce qui était intéressant par exemple
quand on discutait avec les entreprises
de ma circonscription dans les yvelines
c'est que certaines disait moi j'ai pris
le prêt de garantie de l'état au cas où
si un jour vous avez une pénurie de
trésorerie et en même temps iliad mener
ses démarches auprès du gouvernement et
auprès des services de l'état il y avait
en parallèle une adaptation de leur
fonctionnement pour justement pouvoir
faire face à cette crise
et c'est particulièrement un tour de
force des entreprises parce que on a eu
beaucoup d'incertitudes dans cette crise
mais je crois aussi qu'il faut saluer
que ça a été la résidence des
entreprises pendant cette crise elle a
été possible grâce à finalement une très
forte réactivité de l'état dans la mise
en place de dispositifs efficaces qui
ont permis d'accompagner les entreprises
tout au long des différentes étapes
d'abord des mesures de soutien avec le
club garantie de l'état mais aussi le
fonds de solidarité qui a permis à ceux
qui avaient qui a été fermée
administrativement de passer le cap
et puis des par exemple des mesures qui
ce qui était lié à aux échéances
fiscales avec un report de ces 2 c et 2
c gestion donc là je crois que c'est
très intéressant
cette ce dialogue très fuite s'est
instauré entre les services de l'état et
les entreprises ce qui leur a permis du
coup de faire face dans les meilleures
conditions à la crise économique
là on sait que voilà ces deux dernières
années ont été un petit peu chahuté avis
aubry on n'a pas adressé de résilience
mais ce qu'il ya aussi du déni une
difficulté à se rendre compte de la
situation voire de faire appel à la
justice commerciale
je dirais que c'est pas propre à la
situation que nous connaissons de crise
sanitaire
malheureusement il
faites un sommet de chefs d'entreprise
ne veulent pas toujours voir les
difficultés dans laquelle ils sont le
tribunal a la possibilité lorsqu'il à
certains indices montrant que les
entreprises ont des difficultés
il peut convoquer le chef d'entreprise
et donc c'est le souvent le président
qui fait cela ou one ses juges délégués
et il peut convoquer le chef
d'entreprise pour qu'il vienne
s'expliquer des difficultés qu'ils
pourraient rencontrer et bien souvent on
constate que certains de ces chefs
d'entreprise ne voient pas qu'ils sont
en difficulté ils pensent toujours que
leur client va les payer
ils pensent toujours qu'ils vont
recevoir une commande mais souvent de ce
fait ils retardent des prises de
décisions qui sont nécessaires et le
tribunal de commerce en la matière à des
dispositifs juridiques pour permettre
aux entreprises de sortir de leur de la
crise dans laquelle elles peuvent être
certaines de ces outils sont
confidentielles je pense à ce qu'on
appelle le monde à doc et la
conciliation port traiter de ces
difficultés de manière confidentielle
est un atout absolument indispensable
parce que cela ne détériore pas la
notorité l'image de l'entreprise si
jamais on sait qu'une entreprise
malheureusement vient en redressement ou
en liquidation judiciaire
les créanciers les fournisseurs ne vont
pas continuer à travailler avec elle
donc ça c'est un différend savent faire
appel au tribunal ce n'est pas trop tard
il faut l'enfer est fait il faut le
faire et les entreprises doivent
anticiper la solution ses dans
l'anticipation et les outils que je
viens d'évoquer donc que entre dans
cette possibilité pour les entreprises
de trouver des solutions de manière
confidentielle
elles sont épaulées par un professionnel
de la restructuration si derrière ce
sont des personnes qui connaissent
parfaitement ce type de situations qui
vont par exemple aller négocier avec les
créanciers que ce soit les créanciers
fiscaux sociaux ou avec le bailleur ou
avec le banquier des échelonnements 2
hors dette et de ce fait l'entreprise
sera sécurisé et je pense que pour
celles qui ont traversé la crise et qui
pensent que elles vont pouvoir peut-être
avoir des difficultés parce qu'il ya
bien un moment il faudra rembourser
d'éventuelles dettes antérieures et
faire face au fonctionnement nouveau
qu'elle reprenne et dans ces conditions
certainement des difficultés il ne faut
pas qu'elles hésitent à franchir la
porte du tribunal
j'insiste là dessus parce que beaucoup
de justement craignent que finalement on
les liquides
souvent certains disent que le primat de
commerce il faut sourire les entreprises
je m'élève contre cela le chef
d'entreprise qui vient au tribunal et
qui demande en quelque sorte de l'aide
auprès du président du tribunal sera
toujours bien accueillis et on trouvera
des solutions pour lui donc anticiper ne
pas hésiter à nous rencontrer le 1er
juin dernier les ministres de l'économie
de la justice présenté le dispositif
d'accompagnement des entreprises dans la
sortie de crise il se fera sur trois
piliers la détection précoce
l'orientation est là et l'accompagnement
des entreprises mal et le bec monsieur
ouvrir la part laissée la détection se
fera de manière confidentielle
là aussi dans ce cadre oui je crois que
dans tous les cas c'est important cette
confidentialité qui peut être garanti
or aux chefs d'entreprises parce que
c'est un élément aussi de réassurance
quant à la volonté de l'état et des
services de l'état de les aider et de
les accompagner et nous pas de mettre en
péril leur activité
c'est un élément de l'assurance mais je
crois que vous l'avez surtout bien dit
ce qui est fondamental et c'est aussi ce
que tu te président brille c'est d'avoir
cette détection précoce
parce que plus on est capable
d'identifier les entreprises en
difficulté plus on va pouvoir adapter
les outils à à la bonne réponse
moi j'ai rencontré il ya de ça
maintenant 15 jours à peu près la
direction générale des finances
publiques qui a fait ce travail
d'accompagnement est effectivement même
nous parlementaires dont je n'ai pas
forcément d'un troll quand nous leur
avons fait remonter
dossier de 13 en amont a vu que tout de
suite n'avait pu apporter les bonnes
solutions aux entreprises et des
entreprises de trouver les moyens peut
reprendre je crois que c'est fondamental
d'avoir cette détection précoce qui se
fera par le biais des données croisées
de l'ensemble des services de l'état
parce que le premier pas dans une
difficulté ça peut être une créance
impayée des auprès d'eux notamment des
services de l'urssaf ou d'autres
d'autres services et puis après ça peut
s'enchaîner très vite donc je crois que
c'est important aussi de mutualiser
l'information entre les différents
services
il ya aussi un numéro unique on l'a vu
s'afficher à l'écran qui permet d'être
orientés selon les difficultés
rencontrées et xavier aubry les
tribunaux de commerce seront bien sûr
sollicité par l'intermédiaire de leurs
greffiers en proposant soit des
diagnostics gratuits soit en proposant
des rendez-vous de sortie de crise c'est
des situations que vous connaissez déjà
quel est le parcours d'une entreprise en
difficulté alors le parcours qui se
passe bien
encore une fois c'est déjà d'avoir
conscience de ces difficultés et de
passes sans fermer en disant demain ça
ira mieux plus on démarre tôt plus on a
des chances de s'en sortir donc la porte
du tribunal encore une fois est ouvert
par exemple dans notre tribunal
les chefs d'entreprise peuvent venir
sans rendez-vous tous les mardis après
midi pour rencontrer un avocat
gratuitement et évoquer éventuellement
les difficultés qu'ils rencontrent ces
rendez vous sont à prendre effectivement
facilement ils viennent et ils ont la
possibilité d'avoir une consultation
rapide
ils peuvent aussi rencontrer les
administrateurs judiciaires qui
travaillent sur le ressort des tribunaux
de commerce de versailles et qui
pourront justement leur donner un
certain nombre de conseils pour adopter
la bonne stratégie et éventuellement
donc venir devant le tribunal pour
demander l'ouverture d'un mandat d'un
coup d'une conciliation donc ensuite le
processus car effectivement ça suit un
certain nombre de règles
chen entreprises déposent une requête
personnellement en tant que président je
reçois ce chef d'entreprise je discute
avec lui des conditions dans lesquelles
cette demande peut être acceptée et
ensuite le jeune homme à
l'administrateur judiciaire ou un
mandataire judiciaire mais généralement
l'administrateur judiciaire pour épauler
le chef d'entreprise dans le cadre de ce
processus de prévention amiable
confidentielles et qui dans 7 cas sur 10
abouti à un accord et une sortie
positive de la crise rencontrée par
l'entreprise donc encore une fois
j'insiste il faut pas hésiter à venir et
à de faire la possibilité d'utiliser ces
outils dans l'intérêt de l'entreprise tu
crois que c'est efficace c'est tout à
fait originale puisque nous sommes à la
veille de la transposition d'une
directive européenne sur ces sujets
c'est tout à fait originale aucun autre
pays n'a seul type de dispositif et
cette directive c'est tout partie
inspirée du droit français
donc en la matière le sommes en avance
et il faut pas hésiter effectivement à
utiliser ses outils
marie lebey qu'est ce que le dispositif
judiciaire peut être aussi amené à
évoluer au regard de la crise de la
crevette qui amènent des situations peut
être plus complexe qu'avant cette
situation elle nous a tous profondément
bouleversés et donc elle n'a obligé
totalement à réadapter nous fassions
faire nous nous vient entre active monde
économique est bon de politiques et
administratifs et on croit que
finalement la pression qui a été mise
par cette crise est plutôt bénéfique
puisqu'elle vous a permis de vous
adapter rapidement et quand on regarde
par exemple le rapport qui est de la
cour des comptes qui a été commandé en
février je crois et qui a été remis très
récemment au gouvernement et à la
commission des finances à l'assemblée
nationale
il est noté que les mesures de soutien
et d'accompagnement qui nous ont été
mises en place
france on a bien fonctionné donc je
crois que dans le cas pour que cette
crise il faut pas s'interdire de penser
peut-être un peu en dehors du cadre et
que si c'était nécessaire est peut-être
d'ailleurs sur les recommandations et
des présidents des tribunaux de commerce
serait potentiellement intéressant de
réfléchir à au moins mieux accompagner
nos entreprises dans ce qu'elles se
retrouvent dans des situations
économiques qui sont compliquées on a
parlé des secteurs qui sont concernés
c'est plutôt les plus touchés c'est
l'hôtellerie la restauration la toux du
mit aussi l'industrie manufacturier le
commerce mais est ce que ce sont 1
arrive avec des pme des tpe des grands
groupes qui seront les plus concernés
par ce dispositif
c'est très je pense que c'est très
variable en fonction de la situation des
filières à chaque fois il ya un regard
qui est porté
on a des dispositifs qui permettent de
répondre de manière différenciée en
fonction c'est une pme outils là dans le
cadre des dernières annonces qui ont été
qui ont été faites par le ministre bruno
le maire est le garde des sceaux et
dupond moretti à des dispositifs bien
sûr suis accompagné les plus petites
entreprises avec une avance remboursable
que jusqu'à avec dans la limite des
puissants 1000 euros et sur une maturité
de 10 ans elle publie à bonifier pour
une durée maximale de six ans on ne se
sont plutôt dispositif s'adresse aux
plus facile de raisonner en point bas
s'ils me filière se retrouvent en
difficulté c'est le plan de relance ne
suffisait pas à stimuler sa reprise
j'imagine que l'état serait au chevet
puisque l'idée qu'on a la philosophie
qu'on a mis en place dans le dos cette
crise depuis le début c'est de dire il
faut que pour une entreprise notre
activité économique à cette crise va
être estime en outre en termes de en
termes de pertes d'entreprise de pertes
d'emplois et voir il faut que ce soit
une opportunité pour les entreprises
pour être plus compétitifs plus que bien
sûr ça dépendra vraiment des secteurs
des filières de la façon dont bras être
moins impactées et je crois que c'est
pour ça qu'on passe du poids qui nous
coûtent aux quoi qu'il arrive c'est
qu'on va regarder avec beaucoup de
qui pour être oui à des fragilités et
xavier aubry est ce que aussi vous voyez
vous suivait depuis deux ans des
entreprises qui seraient restés pérenne
sans la crise de la cofidis à la crise
sanitaire aussi bouleversé tout type de
société donc je crois que il faut voir
les choses avec un côté assez positif
parce que une entreprise qui a des
fondements sas donc qui a des capitaux
propres suffisants qui un fonds de
roulement pour assurer justement la
trésorerie nécessaire pour acheter des
marchandises est en attente de leur
revente et du paiement de leurs clients
eh bien elles ont traversé correctement
la crise
il est très étonnant de constater que je
vais look citer un exemple de cet après
midi une chef d'entreprise est venu me
voir elle était jusqu'à présent dans un
secteur d'activité où il y avait une
fermeture administrative depuis
plusieurs mois et ça fait partie des
secteurs qui ont rouvert la depuis le
noble bien cette personne a réagi par
anticipation
elle avait une grosse dette auprès de
son bailleur et ça c'est un des sujets
majeurs des difficultés des entreprises
des dettes bancaires bien évidemment
elle avait obtenu 1 pg e mais elle va
sortir de la crise parce qu'elle avait
gardé la trésorerie elle n'avait pas
utilisé son p jeu pendant cette période
de fermeture
et dans ces conditions elle va rebondir
assez facilement elle nous a demandé
effectivement l'ouverture d'une
conciliation pour négocier avec son
bailleur un étalement d'une dette
importante mais je pense qu'elle pourra
s'en sortir sans difficulté donc si vous
voulez il ya des solutions il ya des
entreprises qui ont traversé la crise
avec le maintien d'une certaine
trésorerie comme celle que je viens de
citer
et je voudrais juste pour répondre
peut-être à votre question précédent
dire que selon une étude récente la de
l'entreprise altares les secteurs
économiques qui ont le plus souffert
mais ça n'a rien d'étonnant c'est
effectivement en le premier la
construction ensuite le commerce des
services aux entreprises est en
quatrième position contrairement à ce
qu'on pouvait imaginer le secteur de la
restauration et de l'hôtellerie
donc ce ne sont pas eux qui sont les
premiers touchés dans le cadre des
difficultés des entreprises au cours de
cette période 2020 2021 et j'ajouterais
deuxième observation aussi à cet égard
que contrairement à ce qu'on pouvait à
temps
c'était toujours selon cette étude ce
n'était pas nécessairement les plus
petites entreprises qui étaient en
mauvaise posture mais les entreprises
dites moyennes ou les entreprises de
taille intermédiaire qu'on appelle pays
qui ont connu effectivement plus de
difficultés et on l'a vu dans les médias
un certain nombre de grandes enseignes
commerciales qui ont connu en 2020 2021
des difficultés majeures et donc c'est
assez paradoxal de ce point de vue là
donc les petites ou petites entreprises
n'ont pas si mal traversé la crise
actuelle sur le plan économique n'est
pas la raison de toutes ces fermetures
de toutes celles qui risquerait
d'arriver finalement est ce qu'il
faudrait pas changé aussi le
fonctionnement de certaines entreprises
pour caser de la trésorerie qu'elle ait
des fonds de roulement des fonds propres
marie le bec je crois que c'est quand
même ce dont on a travaillé au cours de
trois premières années du mandat du
président de la république c'est à dire
avoir des entreprises qui soit plus
agile plus compétitifs plus innovantes
qu'ils puissent investir plus facilement
notamment en renforçant leur alors qu'on
croit après ça on l'a fait à travers de
plusieurs plusieurs textes de loi je
pense que j'assure aux ordonnances
travail qui assouplit le marché du
travail qui permet une fluidité en cas
de difficultés je pense bien sûr à la
loi passe qui a permis de travailler sur
toutes les questions enfin un peu tous
les carcans
trotter la question des seuils sociaux
par exemple la question du renforcement
de la participation l'intéressement et
enfin le renforcement des fonds propres
la capacité à innover la meilleure
protection des brevets dont bien sûr
cette crise parce que ça peut être un
accélération des difficultés des
entreprises comme pour la rencontrer il
y avait je crois en france et c'était un
des éléments forts de notre campagne en
beaucoup d'éléments de blocage notamment
dans le monde économique les a
certainement pas tous levés on n'a
certainement pas répondu à tous les
sujets mais je crois qu'au cours des
trois premières années du mandat on
s'est vraiment à donner à cette question
de dire comment est ce qu'on fait pour
que la france soit un pays
et vous monsieur aubry en tant que
président du tribunal de commerce de
versailles quand vous voyez les
situations arrivée est ce que c'est
aussi un changement de mentalité qu'il
faut prévoir quand on se lance c'est
vrai que pour se lancer soyons clair il
faut quand même que le jeune chef
d'entreprise qui a eu démarrer une
activité un vrai projet un projet qui
soit construit un projet qui puisse être
e financés et pas uniquement par emprunt
il n'y a pas de doute qu'une entreprise
qui démarre avec des capitaux propres
même si c'est utile pour faire la
création d'entreprise avec un euro de
capital c'est peut-être sympathique de
voir sa création mais on peut douter sur
le temps que elle pourra rencontrer des
difficultés et quel travail sera plus
difficilement une éventuelle crise donc
je crois que tout le monde ne peut pas
devenir entrepreneur il faut un certain
nombre de conditions et des conditions à
la fois de définition d'un projet de
formation il est important qu'un chef
d'entreprise sache que c'est qu'à un
fonds de roulement que des clients il
faut les relancer ils ne paieront pas
toujours spontanément d'avoir une
comptabilité qui tienne la route et dans
ces conditions on a de bonnes chances
pour avoir un suivi satisfaisant et voir
le développement d'entreprises mais en
la matière on a un peu relâché me
semble-t-il
ces conditions dans le passé quand on
voulait créer une entreprise il fallait
se former obligatoirement auprès de la
chambre de commerce
c'est l'industrie ceci pour essayer de
développer l'entrepreneuriat a été
supprimé je ne suis pas sûr que à tous
les coups on n'est gagné pour la matière
parce que d'aucuns se lance mais ils
n'ont pas les les bases essentielles de
gestion et donc qu'ils n'ont pas d'
alerte et un moment donné ils sont dans
une impasse et à ce moment là
l'entreprise qu'ils ont créés dans
lequel ils ont donné leur temps leur
coeur demandez peut-être de l'aide à des
amis pour financer le démarrage est bien
risque de disparaître
donc il ya des situations humaines qui
sont difficiles aussi je vous propose
qu'on s'arrête sur ces mots ce que le
temps file
ce statut de société maintenant terminé
merci de nous avoir suivi on se retrouve
la semaine prochaine pour un nouveau
temps d'échangé d'ici là prenez soin de
vous
[Musique]